mais quand vous êtes sur un déplacement
et que président et qu'à un moment vous
apercevez quelqu un quelque chose qui
n'est pas en cohérence avec ce que vous
aviez préparé
vous n'allez pas attendre que le colonel
lavergne ou son adjoint le commissaire
perroudon soit votre droite soit votre
bouche vous pouvez aller faire la
remarque gentiment et il n'est pas
obligé d'en disposer
l'officier de sécurité pour lui dire à
ce que est ce que c'est possible de se
décaler un peu pour les images s voilà
c'est quelque chose de c'est la logique
de terrain s'il décide de me dire non je
me déclarerai pas eh bien il se décale
pas et je vais chercher le colonnel
lavernhe qu'ils veulent mais c'est
jamais arrivé c'est jamais arrivé
monsieur ben là pardon
cher jean pierre sueur informiez vous le
gspr à chaque fois que vous étiez partie
prenante d'un déplacement et que vous
portiez une arme le j'espère le
savait-il alors le principe même quand
on a une autorisation de port d'armes à
titre exceptionnel même si c'est pas la
formulation administrative exact c'est
qu'elle soit portée d'une manière
discrète donc je ne me balade est pas
pendant les déplacements du président de
la république avec les armes apparentes
c'était une garantie pour ma sécurité
personnelle et là dessus comme je
voulais dit si à un moment j'ai pu et
c'est arrivé peut-être trois fois en un
an nous retrouver sur un déplacement
officiel ou un déplacement privé avec
mon arme à la ceinture et le président
de la république pas très loin le siège
était informé que je l'avais mon arme
sur moi mais c'était pour des motifs
personnels parce qu'à un moment parfois
vous n'avez pas le temps de passer à
l'elysée vous partez de chez vous
directement parce que le déplacement
était monté à la dernière minute mais
c'est arrivé trois fois donc en aucun
cas il n'aurait pu y avoir une haie et
ci s'était passé quelque chose
si le président avait été attaqué à un
moment où pour une raison que j'ignore
mon rôle n'était pas de la sortir il ya
des professionnels qui sont là pour ça
et on est intégré dans la bulle qui
conçoit le service de presse était donc
je n'y a pas eu d'interférence jamais
entre mois elle j'espère